to probably to probably get uh  to the first place for the first time  i mean technically we are now unclear  first  but it's it's quite clear that uh  like our main driver will probably win  and he will be ahead again  so we basically need to  [Music]  uh need to win one more game before like  each of us  starts as a  the next one okay let's go for some g4  then  normally if you need to win  quickly you go for some  random attack  yeah and i think we are given a chance  to finish it okay takes  queen h5  g6 and this is it  now let's just hope the guy will not  sing for too long  okay queen h5 is still the move  just don't spend your two minutes water  yeah you're lost like bishop g6 check  i can even pre-move it so bishop j6  check  and then queen h7  he resigns okay very well